let's talk a little bit more about that
variable that Bob mentioned and
understand a little bit more about
fetterman's condition we're going to
bring in our medical contributor David
Aegis uh David good morning before we
get to the first question we should
point out uh you have not spoken to
fetterman's doctors you are not his
doctor so we're talking generally here
about the auditory processing issue that
was evident in the interview yesterday
what can you tell us about it generally
speaking
thank you Tony
um you know fetterman had an irregular
heart rhythm called atrial fibrillation
where his Atrium didn't contract all the
way and was beating very quickly and
what happened is a blood clot happened
there and traveled to the brain where it
went in the brain it blocked blood and
oxygen from getting in and that causes
damage in the brain this area was
involved in auditory processing that is
taking words or sounds and converting
them to words that the brain can
understand so he can't make that
conversion well most of the recovery
after a stroke happens in the first
three months or so he's at month five
can more recovery happen it's certainly
possible but it's certainly not
guaranteed
so where would you say he is in the
recovery process uh and how long might
it take before we know for certain
whether this goes away or doesn't
well we know he's made significant
recovery right his wife noticed that his
face was drooping and there were other
issues much of which have resolved which
is fantastic for him at the same time he
still has this auditory processing that
was evident by having to use this a
teleprompter or this this being able to
convert words into letters that he can
read so his graphical processing the eye
processing is perfect the problem is is
that auditory processing and getting
full recovery five months out doesn't
happen in many cases and so he may be
reliant on these devices that convert
words into graphical elements or
something he can see and be able to
translate in his brain and so this may
be with him for a lifetime but we just
don't know
yeah and it'll be up to voters to decide
whether that's significant or not as Bob
Costa put it it's a variable uh Dr David
Aegis thank you very much